bonjour vers a expliqué nous quel est le
thème du forum cette année bonjour sophy
cette année le thème du forum c'est
l'économie de la nouvelle réalité
c'est-à-dire l'ère post qu'ovide le
forum se tient après une pause de
l'année dernière et du coup maintenant
la communauté d'affaires et les hommes
politiques et doivent discuter de la
manière comment on va vivre dans ce
monde post qu'ovide l'événement central
du forum c'est traditionnellement à la
session plénière cette année y
participent
le chancelier autrichien et l'émir du
qatar et qui seront en vidéoconférence
cantat président de président russe
vladimir poutine lui va participer en
personne et selon son porte parole
dmitri peskov
dans son intervention le président russe
va aborder des sujets socio-économiques
ainsi que la question d'investissement
et du développement est alors quelles
sont les mesures sanitaires de
précaution qui ont été instaurées dans
ce contexte de pandémie
beaucoup d'instruction effectivement
cette année au forum et notamment le
nombre de participants a été limité à
5000 personnes ce qui n'est pas beaucoup
pour le forum de saint pétersbourg et
chacun de ses 5000 participants a dû
passer un test de détection du
coronavirus qui devait être négatif
afin de faire activer son badge d'entrée
et donc je dois vous dire que même les
organisateurs même et tous ceux qui
travaillent sur le forum et ils ont dû
être vaccinés pour pour peut travailler
ici il faut également dire que partout
sur le forum il ya des capteurs
thermiques qui bloque les badges des
gens dont la team p température est trop
élevée
merci beaucoup verhaeghe hoffman en bien
et de saint-pétersbourg on vous
retrouvera tout au long de ce forum
économique à plus tard
[Musique]